los puentes de acceso están destrozados
para impedir el paso de las tropas rusas
en plena ofensiva el ejército ucraniano
nos autoriza llegar hasta el frente Sur
la guerra se difumina entre pueblos
retomados y fronteras invisibles la
contraofensiva se ve cerca estamos viaja
ndo este pueblo está dividido en dos Al
otro lado del río donés se posiciona en
las tropas rusas olec es comandante II
del ejército ucraniano desde su posición
controla el movimiento de los soldados
rusos
esta primera línea es de la destrucción
de morteros recibimos Aviación
artillería Pero lo que más recibimos son
morteros luchamos contra todos
está tan solo un kilómetro del frente y
en esta ciudad ahora mismo ya lo pueden
ver hay tranquilidad pero es lo más
terrorífico de esta guerra convencional
que un ataque puede pasar en cualquier
momento
los niños juegan en el parque Parece que
la guerra da un respiro pero Valentina
no puede controlar el dolor que está
viviendo
nos preocupamos por todas las personas
ahora Estamos todos juntos Unidos vamos
todos para uno y uno para todos
en los pueblos retomados por el ejército
ucraniano la imagen Es muy distinta en
rusca ya lo soba todos son ruinas y
restos que las tropas rusas dejaron en
su vida incluso estas zonas recuperadas
continúan siendo inestables Y es que la
primera línea en esta guerra en Ucrania
se difumina entre sus carreteras estamos
en una de las zonas recuperadas en la
zona de harkif y en estos momentos
seguimos escuchando el sonido de la
artillería muy cercana en las puertas de
los vecinos de las zonas ocupadas se
puede leer la palabra smotrin casa
inspeccionada en ruso son los restos de
la invasión en la primera línea del
frente en Ucrania